dernier témoin qui craignent un avant la
frontière russe
malgré les apparences la situation est
tendue le nedo ce matin ils ont bombardé
grâce au pilier plus tôt ils ont
bombardé par ici aussi on voit les
cratères il vise les checkpoints et ça
tombe aussi sur la bande
à chris noth pilia la ville la plus
proche un obus a atterri ici dans ce
potager aucun blessé mais les fenêtres
ont toutes été soufflée par l'explosion
[Musique]
partir ou rester
alexandre a eu mille fois cette
discussion avec sa femme mais pour ce
pompier impossible d'abandonner sa
mission impossible d'abandonner sa
maison est venu tous mes amis sont ici
tous mes collègues tous les gens que je
connais je ne veux pas partir tout ce
qu'on veut c'est que ça s'arrête le plus
vite possible et que les russes eux
repartent chez eux
en l'occurrence les russes qui ont
occupé cette région l'ont effectivement
quitté repoussés par les forces
ukrainienne à la fin mars
depuis le kremlin s'est concentré sur
l'est et le sud du pays mais ici dans le
nord les frappes n'ont jamais
complètement cessé this commis sept ans
dans à peu près un mois le district n'a
pas été frappé une seule fois et tout le
monde se disait ça va bientôt être la
fin mais ça a recommencé sa hausse à
cette maison a été bombardée en juin le
couple qui vivait ici a survécu malgré
des blessures
les russes prépare-t-il une nouvelle
incursion dans la région de soumis son
gouverneur pense plutôt que non mais qu
ils maintiennent la pression pour des
raisons stratégiques trois mois nous
devons défendre la frontière et nous
assurer qu'ils n'essaient pas de
pénétrer dans les régions libérées et ce
pilonnage constant leur permet de
distraire les forces ukrainienne et les
fixes et loin des lignes de front actif
vous ai vu peux vous dire que oui
c'est après une défaite cuisante que les
forces d'occupation russes ont quitté la
région de soumis au mois de mars
derrière moi l'un de leurs tanks détruit
mais le danger posé aux populations
civiles et aux forces armées
ukrainiennes qui défendent cette région
n'est pas parti pour autant